So let me elaborate on,
[INAUDIBLE]
on what
said about learning the brain. Neuroscientist Eric Kandel conducted round
breaking research in the learning of neuro growth and it led fact to a Nobel
prize. One of Kandel's big insights in setting learning in the brain came from
realizing it would be best to study in an animal with the simple. Rather than
complex nervous system. And one with really big nodes, ones we can actually see
with a naked eye. The perfect animal for this was the sea snail, he wanted to
see what happened, but the neural level when these animals learned, in the
short term versus the long term. So we administered a single shot to activate
short term learning. And saw that the snail learned a defensive response, it
lasted for about ten minutes. But if the shock was administered four or five
times the animals learned defense was long term, lasting days. But here's the
discovery that lead to the Nobel Prize, Kandell was the first neuroscientist to
discover how long-term learning happens at the neural level. He discovered
there were new proteins in the neurons for long-term learning, but not in the
short-term learning. And, these new proteins led to new neural structures, in
short, to neural growth. Upon further research, Kandel uncovered how these
proteins form that led to new neural growth. Let's look at this figure. In this
neuron, we see a sensory neuron connected to a motor neuron and some activating
neurotransmitter glutamate being released. This is the base line. Here in this
figure we see what happens in short term. Learning and memory. When a mild
stimulus is presented, more glutamate is released, strengthening the synaptic
connection. But note, there's no new neural structures that are growing. Now in
this image, we see what happens in long-term learning and memory. In response
to a strong stimulus. So many stimuli are being presented. The signal, then,
goes up the axon to the nucleus of the cell, turning on particular genes, or a
set of genes, and then synthesize new proteins to form. These proteins then
create new neural structures down here. And even more glutamate is produced and
received by the motor neuron. So these new structures and strong synaptic
connections stay for days and days. Leading to long term memory and learning.
The moral of the story, is that long term learning changes your brain in a way
that short term learning and memory do not. A finding worthy of a nobel prize.
Now go out out and learn this material and change your brain for good.